you've been faithful and you've you've
had results yeah and you're and you're
seeing lives transformed through your
work and so
people who see that are going to want to
deploy more resources and we expect god
to bless this ministry and provide you
more resources so that you can help more
people absolutely
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november the 20th to
february 28th bring to you the awareness
that you need to know about violence on
the south side of chicago but also to
raise as much money as possible to build
a community center on this much needed
block called o block it's called o block
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs took the o in his name and
start calling it o block well we decided
we like the o so we're going to change
it though to opportunity block i want to
thank fox for giving me the opportunity
every single day to bring to you rooftop
revelations where i share with you my
thoughts viewpoints and opinions on
matters across chicago and our great
country every now and then i get to
bring you a guest as well and so today
i'm really excited because i have a very
special guest that i want to share with
all of you his name is jim bakke he is
the ceo of barnabas foundation so jim
welcome well thank you it's really great
to be up here thanks for hosting me
today you're doing doing our ceo
challenge and we really appreciate it
and um
we've issued it out to all the ceos
across the country to come and spend the
night with us and help us make awareness
and raise funds and you took that
challenge and we really appreciate it
let me jump right in okay
the first question i want to ask you is
what i ask a lot of people and that is
why are you here on the south side of
chicago
on a roof
in the cold
on this very night what's what is that
about
[Music]
well let's let's start where uh our our
staff started we were talking about
trying to do something that would honor
dr martin luther king and dr martin
luther king day and as we were talking
about it we were talking we were asking
what are some ministries that are really
doing a great job in the city of chicago
and we thought of yours and so we wanted
to do something on that day and timing
got a little bit short so we decided to
try to do something in february
and one of our staff mentioned that you
did this rooftop and you allowed ceos to
come and stay up here
and so
in a lark i just said
hey i'll do it and
uh before i knew it the
the invitation came and the arrangements
were made and here i am absolutely
absolutely and we're glad you're here
you know one of the things you said is
that you know you all did some research
to find out about project hood and i
know we do some work with you all um but
but
what are your thoughts about project
project hood from what you know and
after spending some time up here today
what are your thoughts
well i love what i hear and i love what
i see happening here because
in this world you know if we just watch
the news we can hear all the problems
for chicago and all the concerns about
gun violence but uh who's really coming
up with solutions and
attacking that problem
well your ministry is one of those and
as i learned more about it i realized
this is one
where
you're seeing results as i saw what you
were doing as we talked today i see
results and i see the the right focus of
ministry and so we're just honored to
partner with you well we really
appreciate it you know it is about
solutions because so many times um
people are trying to solve these
problems these complex issues like
education and economics and
fatherlessness and
they're not doing it with solutions it's
a lot of talk
but we really work hard to try to
provide solutions and
it's important that we have
organizations like barnabas that to come
alongside and to assist can you tell us
a little bit about what barnabas does
and and why they do it sure
uh
in a nutshell
in a nutshell barnabas helps generous
christians
transfer their wealth and make gifts
of the resources god has entrusted to
them
in ways that honor god provide for their
families but also support ministries
close to their heart
specifically we help in the area that's
called plan giving gifts in a will gifts
of real estate gifts of stock or
business interest and so we're basically
helping people make tax advantage giving
to organizations close to their heart
right so how does that help
organizations like project hood and
other organizations
um
that may be trying to do things what
what what benefit is that well your
supporters need to figure out how they
can support you in the in the way and
how they can maximize the resources they
want to give to you and so we help
uh
them give more in a more tax advantaged
way so they can give you more uh
resources and so we've partnered you
know we've partnered with a number of
your donors and it's a privilege for us
to work with them to decide what to give
and then get those assets ready to go
and then cut the checks to you right and
you know
partnerships like that are really
important because if we're ever going to
solve some of these issues especially on
the south side of chicago
we believe that building this center is
so important
because it's going to help us to 10x
everything that we do to maximize it so
that our carpentry classes are our uh
resourced so that our trades courses our
resource so that our entrepreneurial
things our resource our trauma
counseling and all of that is resource
and it's so important that we partner
with organizations like barnabas
and there's other organizations that are
out there absolutely that are extremely
important to help things move forward um
but yeah so
you know we really believe that what
jesus said about what who is faithful
with little
will be entrusted with much and he was
faithful as little of then can be
trusted to be faithful with much and so
what we love about what we see at
project hood and and new beginnings is
that
you've been faithful and you've you've
had results yeah and you're and you're
seeing lives transformed through your
work and so
people who see that are going to want to
deploy more resources and we expect god
to bless this ministry and provide you
more resources so that you can help more
people absolutely so it's again it's an
honor to partner with you yeah thank you
and you know that and that's a principle
that we teach that if god is giving you
something you have to be accountable of
it you have to um nurture it develop it
do all the things that are required so
that they can be blessed and so you know
we are extremely grateful for your being
here and we're extremely grateful for
what barnabas does not just with us but
but real quick tell us about some of the
other organizations that you all are a
blessing to
well
we are partnered with about 200
ministries everything from christian
grade schools christian high schools
colleges and universities seminaries wow
uh
evangelism ministries uh
relief and development ministries bible
distribution
uh social service type ministries
uh all of them are distinctively
christian
christ-centered understanding that
everything we have is god's and we are
just stewards of his resources and so
then we just be faithful and allow god
to flow through us into the lives of
others for his glory absolutely i was
thinking about something as you were
talking and saying that um do you think
that
organizations like barnabas
are able to do the work that government
cannot do
or is not doing
yeah so this is the you know
the argument should we have uh public
funding for all these things or should
we have private funding and i think
there's a place for each but we really
believe that uh christ-centered
values-focused ministries are probably
more efficient and can do a more
effective job than government
intervention and so that's why that's
why i've dedicated my life to the
not-for-profit sector and this and in
particular the christian community
because i really believe that
that is how we can most effectively help
people and and partnering with
businesses because we know that
that
business and learning how to do business
well
brings people out of poverty but
government intervention
often is very inefficient yeah and
that's i agree wholeheartedly that's one
of the reasons why
project hood is so focused because we
believe that too that
government intervention or government uh
is not that good at pulling people out
of poverty and helping them to transform
uh transform their lives that that we
are far better at that than any organ
than any government organization and i'm
sure you feel the same way with barnabas
well
there are there are some essential
services that have to be done by
government yeah and i know that there
are
people who have dedicated their lives to
government work in a variety of ways who
are fully dedicated and trying to do
their dead level best right uh so i
don't want to disparage any anyone who's
in that in in
uh the social service world you know in
a government setting but i do believe
that the private private sector and the
not-for-profit sector can be more
efficient absolutely well thank you as
always uh we really appreciate you being
here tonight and we're gonna have a
great time and thanks for sharing with
all of our listeners on fox uh with
rooftop revelations listen it's been
great we're going to spend some great
time together talking and i'm going to
hear some more things about the barnabas
foundation and all the great work that
they do but i want to thank uh eli
steele
our producer for
giving us a great opportunity to have a
wonderful show
shouts out to fox uh for giving us this
wonderful uh platform and always uh my
main man terrell for filming and making
sure everything is straight uh teamwork
makes the dream work so bless you all
and as i always say every single rooftop
revelations that i can remember god
bless you god bless america and until
tomorrow
another rooftop revelation
peace
peace
you